well I clearly got the answer wrong
being that I was rejected twice so seems
to work out for you let me start with
that so look you're young you wanna
achieve and you're in that first third
part you know I describe my life in this
least three thirds you're in the first
third part but if I would give you some
advice and I'm gonna I'm gonna take some
poetic license I'm not gonna say one
thing please I must say two or three
things here's my view of things now that
I'm a little older dog number one choose
to have kids or not but if you choose to
have kids invest in your kids that's to
me is the most important thing second go
for it have success but bring others
along with you if i look at my
professional success it was when i was
in sales if I shipped a computer to
somebody else's territory I would send
the email saying I think you should get
half vs. the managers having to be
involved I remember it started then if
we do something while at Sequoia so we
win take as many people with you for the
ride as possible if you come across a
jerk let them rot in their misery just
just get away from them and number three
bring it every day get up you know I'm
tell you there are some days I go home
and I am just beat oh my god how much
more can I do this a good night's sleep
I get up in the morning and you bring it
again fearlessly just go go go those
would be not the most important but
that's how I view through life and
you've heard it before think of life
when you've got a half hour left to live
you're not going to think about oh boy
my net worth is X it really should have
been 1.2 x I doubt you're going to think
about that oh boy I only be
coo or vp man i wish i became EVP and i
think about that now clearly you have to
achieve success because that's why you
here because you motivated and I don't
want to short sell that one bit but I
think in that order to care of your kids
your family bring as many people as you
can arrive with you and get away from
the jerks and get up in the morning with
a good night's sleep and just bring it